The Bears season is just
following completely off
the rails. I mean,
realistically, they probably
should have
parted ways with Matt Nagy
earlier on. It's not the way
that Chicago has done things was
this more about Chicago
falling off or
the Vikings do now, quietly, get
back to 500, are going to
have a huge Sunday night game
coming up against the Packers,
not this week, but the following
weekend.
I'm not worried about the
Minnesota Vikings right now.
But what I'm looking at is this
coggle beers and use you heard
the announces all night. They
just could not believe how
poorly coach this team is,
you know, they kept saying how
tough these guys are playing.
These guys are playing tough.
They're doing everything they
can but penalties, turnovers
mistakes, undisciplined play.
Well, who was that? A
reflection of that's a
reflection of their head coach
and the play calling was
absolutely horrendous.
They got it. Like I told you a
couple weeks ago.
With the Bears, when they played
the Green Bay Packers,
they have to surround
Justin Fields with more Talent
all the talent around them is
just pretty good. It's not
anything great. No one
explosive just just basically
average Talent. So if they want
to see him continue to struggle
and think about the defense, the
defense is getting older.
So as Matt Nagy is screwing up,
the Chicago Bears, the defenses
are aging defense
and they're just not the same.
Robert Quinn is their best.
Player right now
and real claws, there's count.
That's right. And there's
countless examples
of young, quarterbacks going
into bad coaching situations
and it just ruins their career,
right? It just ruins it before
they even get started. Their
confidence is gone and my fear
is that,
that could happen to Justin
Fields a longer. They keep Matt
Nagy as his coach. That's what I
don't want to happen. For
Justin Fields. There was a
couple plays last night. I just
thought Fields was doing too
much. This is, what are you
just
like, how long he's holding the
football? Just throwing it. That
Beck's feet right there, man.
Don't take that head. Don't take
that sack Bumble here.
There's another one where he
just is holding the ball for
three or four seconds longer
than he should. He's just
handing the Neil Hunter a sack.
This is it right here on
backwards. You can't do it
another sack. So just no matter
what you're doing. Just
try to get that ball out of your
hands. Even if you're just
throwing it away, when he gets
in trouble, is when he's
holding it for five and six
seconds and in this league,
maybe it'll Hi, O State. You can
and this league it just
never seems to
produce a good result.
So what you're what you're
describing right now is
coaching. That's basically what
I'm describing. I know, or lack
thereof and that's what he
needs. He needs somebody that
he can bond with. We talked
about this that he can bond
with that. He could connect
with.
He's not connecting with Matt
Nagy. He's just not and it's
evident on the field the product
that they're putting
out on the field.
I know, and then nag he's going
nuts. Just losing his cool on
the sidelines, and it's almost
feels like it's just the final
punch, right? It's just in
spinal straight shot one, final
Haymaker, like a tired boxer.
Trying to throw that last big
right hand out there,
even though you lost the fight
and
and that's just what coach Nagy
has come to. And
I don't think it's healthy for
Coach. Nagy. I don't think it's
healthy for this locker room. I
certainly don't think it's
healthy for Justin fields. And I
understand that it's not
the way that the Bears do
business to move on from their
head
coach.
The middle of the season but it
may be time for a new way of
doing business in Chicago. And
that's what I really think
needs to happen.
I agree with what you just said.
Yeah, exactly Paces. Well, is
going to above Nagy. Probably
a similar result. Do you think
the Minnesota Vikings wind up,
making the playoffs now that
they're back to seven and
seven,
few tough games, down the
stretch, like this is a team
that can go into Lambo and be
there in Rogers, in your
opinion.
They're very familiar with Aaron
Rodgers, the going into
Lambeau Field, man. We saw that
atmosphere and we see when,
when he's at home. He's just
special man. Aaron Rodgers is
just special.
And we talk about all the great,
quarterbacks and time
being a leader and as MVP, man,
Aaron Rodgers, is that guy.
And, you know, it's just hard to
bet against them. Every time
I bet against Aaron Rodgers,
I've lost, I learned one thing
don't bet
against Aaron, Rodgers.
I'm right there with you on
that. So, here's, here's what
the Vikings. I have coming down
the home stretch and are at 7
and 72 solar hanging off that
final playoff spot. They got to
play the Rams though. They got
to go to Lambeau. Like we just
talked about and they get the
Bears again. I
don't think they get in if
they're 8989
records. Probably not going to
be good enough. They probably
have to go win at Lambeau or
figure out a way to beat
the Rams, but the Rams are
currently getting hot again,
too.
What about not? Well, what about
if they lose to
the Packers but win against the
Rams and the Bears,
that's the road most likely,
right?
Yep. Yeah. It's yeah, it almost
looks like they have to win all
three, huh?
They've just let so many games
slip away this year
Rod. Like how many fourth
quarters this season for the
Vikings
where they've just lost a game
that they had in the bag or it
felt like that they were going
to win and they just blew it
late. And every single week,
we'd come on this show and go
that those are the ones that
are going to cost them. That's
the game. It's going to cost
them.
And now that you get towards the
back half of the schedule,
all of those close losses of
caught up to him and really
you're probably looking at code
Zimmer coaching for his job.
These last three games. If they
win two out of the three, maybe
keeps it. If they just went one
out of the three, you may be
looking at a couple of teams
right there with an entirely
new regime coming in.
Well, I'm looking I'm looking at
if he doesn't make
the playoffs. How do you keep
Mike Zimmer? How do you keep
them?
He's an older coach. I mean,
he's been there for a long
time. They're not going to the
Superbowl. It's not like
they're
they're fighting for NFC
championships. I just think
that you might have to look at
getting somebody a little
younger, maybe a new Fresh, a
little fresher, and somebody
would have different
perspective.